[Applaudissements]
bonjour à toutes et à tous
je m'appelle Dominique Abbas
mon père est né en avril 1955 quelque
part dans la banlieue de Damas ma mère
elle est née en décembre 1959 au fin
fond d'un village de la campagne
hongroise qui s'appelle tissa furet
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé comment
leur enfant se retrouve-t-il ici le 13
mai 2023 devant vous à Nancy
c'est une histoire de mots et une
histoire d'encre que je vais vous
raconter aujourd'hui une histoire de
mots d'abord presque de colissimo
puisque c'est un peu comme un colis
perdu à la poste que ce jeune garçon
blondinet débarque en France quelque
part aux alentours de 2006 ou 2007
à l'aéroport Charles de Gaulle il faut
savoir que ce jeune garçon que vous
voyez là il n'a pas de grande valeur à
l'époque sur le plan intellectuel
économique philosophique littéraire sa
contribution est assez maigre à la
société
pour la simple raison que ce jeune
garçon il ne comprend rien il y a beau
essayer de d'écouter autour de lui il ne
comprend pas un mot de ce que les gens
racontent ils ne parlent pas la langue
alors il se mur dans la seule arme dont
un enfant puisse se doter le silence il
ne dit pas un mot ça dure trois mois je
dis que c'est normal
ça dure six mois ça commence à devenir
inquiétant ça dure un an on l'emmène
chez l'orthophoniste rien à faire
l'enfant ne parlera pas il faut s'y
résigner alors en toute les histoires de
cause ses parents l'emmènent à l'école
un matin
et puis reçoivent un appel une heure
après de l'enseignante
ils sont catastrophes il répondent pas
il est bien l'enfant il est top il est
nickel il parle il parle
j'avais commencé à parler après plus
d'un an et demi à écouter je crois que
ça a été là la première leçon de ma vie
écouter avant de parler observer avant
d'agir
et puis
à partir de là j'ai parlé de mieux en
mieux de façon peut-être un peu
énervante pour d'autres au point que un
jour où j'étais devenu Premier enfin en
rédaction à l'école à la sortie de
l'école la mère d'un des élèves se
tourne vers son fils il lui dit mais tu
te rends compte même Dominique a fait
mieux que toi
voilà j'ai appris deux choses ce jour-là
d'abord que les mots ont un pouvoir
votre maîtrise des mots votre usage des
mots vous situez dans la société ou si
tu comme acteur et ensuite que les mots
ont un sens qui peuvent élever comme ils
peuvent abaisser
ce jour-là je crois que les mots ont
abaissé tout le monde que ce soit le
pauvre enfant qui se faisait Raboué ou
moi-même ou la mère qui les a prononcé
mais en tout cas ça a été là de leçon
essentielle et puis c'est un mot encore
un mot à l'école un peu plus tard qui
qui m'a beaucoup parlé démocratie c'est
joli démocratie comme mot la libre et
égale participation de chacune et de
chacun à la vie de la cité c'est
fabuleux oui mais comment est-ce
possible quand une large majorité de
gens ne maîtrise pas l'usage de la
parole au pire ne comprends pas comment
d'autres maîtrise l'usage de la parole
et s'en sert pour gagner du pouvoir sur
eux
c'est pourquoi révolter je me rendais à
la Maison des jeunes de mon quartier
j'allais voir le premier animateur que
je trouvais qui était fort compréhensif
et je lui ai expliqué mais quand même
star scandale que personne n'écoute les
jeunes il me dit mais écoute on a des
micros dans la salle à côté tu n'as qu'à
t'en serviront une radio
évidemment ça n'avait aucune chance de
fonctionner on avait 13 ans comment
aurions-nous pu monter une radio
donc on a fait une première émission
une deuxième émission une troisième
émission on a fini en partenariat avec
des radios locales et en ligne et puis
sur une radio européenne qui s'appelle
euradio diffusé à travers toute l'Europe
pour décrypter une fois par mois
l'actualité européenne donc il faut
croire que ça a fini par marcher il faut
même croire que les gens étaient prêts à
écouter
ça c'est pour l'histoire des mots et
puis on a attiré l'attention de la
presse l'attention à l'époque on a réuni
une cinquantaine de jeunes qui ont créé
plus d'une dizaine d'émissions dans
certaines fonctionnent encore sur les
radios locales de la région nantaise
aujourd'hui il faudrait même attirer
l'attention d'une certaine ministre de
l'Écologie de de l'époque qui nous avait
invité à Paris pour en discuter
à tel point que cette maîtrise des mots
était devenue essentielle pour moi
j'avais compris l'intérêt qu'il y avait
à donner du pouvoir aux mots et à
utiliser le pouvoir des mots et c'est
pourquoi on a commencé à se rendre
régulièrement dans les quartiers
populaires et à éduquer à parler à
enseigner aux jeunes comment s'exprimer
en public
ça c'est pour le côté davantage mot et
puis ensuite le côté encre c'est que une
fois que j'ai fait ça je suis aperçu que
j'étais installé quand même dans un
cocon un peu confortable et qu'en fait
je voulais en sortir parce que ce
pouvoir des mots dont je m'étais rendu
compte assez tôt je veux dire un peu
toujours demandé comment m'en servir
comment le rendre utile jusqu'à ce que
je comprenne que le principal usage
qu'on peut faire de la langue c'est bien
de créer du lien c'est bien d'aller vers
l'autre et à partir de là j'ai dédié les
cinq ou six dernières années de ma vie à
créer du lien par l'usage des mots en
février dernier encore à Bruxelles au
Conseil européen sur cette chaise ou
normalement ça soit Emmanuel Macron je
peux dire ça fait un peu quelque chose
quand vous arrivez et on vous emmène on
fait traverser tout le bâtiment on vous
emmène dans cette salle parce que la
sécurité et puis on dit voilà là
normalement c'est le président de la
République qui s'assoit et vous allez
devoir donner une opinion sur ce qu'on
va faire sur les infrastructures
rechargeables pour les véhicules
électriques
que les mots portent et que les mots
portent au-delà des pays au-delà des
frontières on a aussi monté une
université européenne avec notre
université avec 11 autres universités à
travers toute l'Europe qui s'appelle una
Europa dont j'ai eu la chance de
présider le conseiller étudiant ou
n'aurait pas c'est facile c'est l'idée
que on peut demain avoir une licence ou
vous feriez votre première année
d'université à Paris votre deuxième à
Madrid votre troisième à Bologne et à la
fin vous auriez un seul diplôme parce
que le savoir le savoir traverse les
frontières par l'expression de la langue
et par l'expression des mots c'est
d'ailleurs l'une des plus belles choses
que que j'ai apprise dans mon université
quand je suis arrivé un peu impressionné
à Paris après avoir lâché l'angle pour
arriver à Paris je suis arrivé dans un
très bel amphithéâtre qui disait tout au
fond de l'amphithéâtre pas de Chems nous
tenons la paix
les gens qui avaient construit cet
université il y a de siècles ceux qui
l'avaient fondé il y a eu siècle avait
compris que c'était le savoir et la
parole qui portait la compréhension de
l'autre qui portait le dialogue et qui
portait la paix contre la guerre et
contre les terreurs de leur époque
ça fait toujours une aéroport on
continue évidemment à porter les mots à
recevoir à débattre parce qu'il n'y a
que par le débat que se fait la
démocratie parfois avec l'aide d'une
petite quantité d'alcool on était en
février dernier encore en Géorgie pour
discuter de l'Union européenne des
perspectives européennes de la Géorgie
ce pays qui est un peu au confins de
notre continent et en fait on est devenu
très copain avec un député local qui
nous a invité dans sa circonscription et
on a passé la soirée à discuter avec des
députés des citoyens locaux dans un
hôtel en plein milieu du Caucase avec
quelques bouteilles de vin bien entamées
avec modération cependant
et c'est là qu'on s'aperçoit que
l'aspiration à l'échange l'aspiration à
travailler ensemble à avancer ensemble
elle est universelle elle est globale
ça m'a aussi permis toute cette maîtrise
des mots de gagner un ou deux concours
d'éloquence ici c'était sous la coupole
du Panthéon pour le concours
international d'éloquence
c'est évidemment amusant de se retrouver
dans ce genre de cadre et ça permet
surtout de répondre à une question que
je me posais encore deux minutes avant
cette photo que faire que faire quand on
se retrouve là devant 300 personnes qui
vous regardent sous la coupole du
Panthéon en plein Paris un nom qui
évoque Malraux Jaurès Jean Moulin que
faire comment parler comment faire
porter ses idées et ses opinions
deux conseils que je peux vous donner
aujourd'hui la première c'est d'être
intransigeant et de n'accepter aucun
compromis ni sur votre éthos ni sur
votre pathos ni sur votre logo alors
derrière ces termes un peu barbares il y
a du latin il y a du latin qui avait
déjà été compris par les Grecs il y a
2000 ans et qui avait été mis en forme à
l'époque par si c'est ronds un peu plus
tard c'est très facile le bateau c'est
votre capacité à créer de l'émotion à
faire pleurer à faire rire à faire l'un
après l'autre là en même temps que
l'autre a emmener les gens avec vous
parce que vous susciter chez eux
le logo c'est le fond de votre
argumentation parce que vous pouvez être
très bon orateur vous pouvez faire rire
les gens pour les faire pleurer si ça ne
tient pas sur le fond vous allez
facilement vous faire contredire et puis
la dernière chose c'est les TOS alors
les taux c'est un peu compliqué à
définir en gros c'est ce que vous
renvoyez de vous parce que quand je suis
descendu sur scène tout à l'heure et que
je suis arrivé là vous vous êtes fait
une idée sur moi avant même que j'ouvre
la bouche et c'est le cas pour toutes
les situations dans lesquelles vous vous
trouvez dans votre vie vous devez vous
exprimer en public et c'est pourquoi il
ne faut jamais transiger sur les dosses
il faut d'abord savoir ce qu'on renvoie
je sais que parfois je peux avoir l'air
d'être un petit intello parisien
ce n'est pas très grave même si ce n'est
pas forcément le cas et puis une fois
que vous l'avez fait il faut travailler
dessus il faut savoir comment l'adapter
pour arriver à convaincre votre public
ce sont les trois choses et puis sur un
plan peut-être un peu moins technique
c'est Antoine de Saint-Exupéry qui
disait dans le petit prince on ne voit
bien qu'avec le cœur alors je suis petit
blond je ne suis pour autant pas le
petit prince mais je me permettrai quand
même peut-être de compléter on ne parle
bien qu'avec le cœur sur tous les sujets
sur lesquels on a à s'exprimer au
quotidien surtout les enjeux qui font
société surtout ces enjeux là au fond il
y aura toujours quelqu'un de plus
intelligent que vous quelqu'un qui aura
lu plus de livres quelqu'un qui aura
fait plus d'études
ce n'est pas grave il n'est pas
forcément plus qualifié il ne t'a pas
forcément de meilleures choses à dire
parce que il y a en vous tout ce que
vous avez vu tout ce que vous avez lu
tout ce que vous avez vécu et toutes ces
choses là font que vous aurez sur chaque
sujet un point de vue unique alors pour
conclure je voudrais vous appeler
mesdames et messieurs d'abord à ne
jamais avoir peur de parler je crois que
c'est une responsabilité envers les
autres envers la démocratie envers notre
société et ensuite à ne jamais parler
que pour élever les autres et à ne
jamais parler qu'avec le cœur je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]